bei meinem letzten london besuch war
glaube ich die restaurants von gordon
ramsay mein absolutes highlight und er
macht nicht nur restaurants und dann
auch rezepte die wären wir heute testen
und zwar zum frühstück bacon jam also
bacon marmelade mit soft scramble rührei
auf sauerteigbrot
[Musik]
ja das ganze ja schon mit steffen
henssler gemacht heute genau das gleiche
nur dass gordon ramsay bei seinen
gerichten weniger den fokus auf
schnelligkeit liegt also es muss sich
alles in zehn 15 minuten funktionieren
aber die haben es in sich also ich hab
mir schon alles rausgesucht schon
eingekauft und ich sagte so viel das
wird richtig richtig lecker heute dick
geschnittene bacon also etwas dicker
geschnittenen bacon glaube ich und zu
nur drei schreiben ich mache ist eine
einfache portion davon und den schneiden
wir wiederum nochmal in kleine streifen
die wir dann einfach in der pfanne
auslassen werden goldbraun und das
becken fährt werden wir natürlich drin
nach einem tag so zu kommen die gordon
ramsay ist für normalsterbliche
natürlich gar nicht möglich aber seine
rezepte kann man machen kann reiten ein
wenig aus dann werdet ihr gleich sehen
das ganze schöne bacon fett schwimmt in
unserer fahne
und marmelade braucht ihr eigentlich
relativ die zweite durch dass wir über
die kleine portion in einem etwas
größeren pfanne machen geht das ganze
schnell verlernt oder ihr merkt schon
dass fett kommt langsam brauchen sie
werden sich so kleine bisschen perfekt
gegeben dem ganzen noch ein bisschen
mehr zeit aus dem becken richtig
knusprig wird er darin dass wir
natürlich auch genau hingucken dass er
nicht verbrennt aber es riecht schon
sehr sehr lecker und es ist auch ein
deftiges frühstück neugierig aber eins
das bestimmt sehr lecker sein wird ich
glaube wenn ihr das gleich am ende sehe
er das zusammenkommen und so werden wir
genauso überrascht sein wie ich von
diesem bericht
[Musik]
wir haben jetzt unsere kleinen baic mit
chips neige jetzt einmal die fahne so
das becken fed runterläuft wir bacon
schön raus bekommen wir brauchen nämlich
dieses pay day fällt jetzt gleich fürs
weiterkommen dieses pferd geben wir
zwiebeln und schalotten lancieren sie so
dass sie schon mal so eine schöne masse
ergäben weiter vorne war bei kindberg in
köln geben wir dazu etwas traubenzucker
ahornsirup und
jetzt wird das ganze nennt also von
marmelade noch ein wenig kaffee ist
spätestens jetzt ist wirklich einfach
nur verwirrend und so hoffen wir dass
ganz sehr schön ein ist für eine
marmelade gemacht haben die doch schon
ganz gut aus und es riecht upgraden also
der kaffee der verdammten so ist ganz
verrückt ein bisschen stunde einkaufen
nicht ganz so heißt sein haben unseren
job eigentlich schon fertig eben
allerdings für den punch chiliflocken
wow das sieht doch super aus alter
wirklich gespannt wie das ganze
schmecken webseiten der kainz angeben
der weg hart genug dann fehlen uns noch
zwei sachen und zwar das brot und ein
rührei
[Musik]
[Applaus]
war verspätet das sieht wirklich
krankenhaus ist sieht so gut aus und das
ist wirklich eine sache von der ich
nicht mal gehört habe
so sieht sich auf welchen jam geröstetes
sauerteigbrot software mit ex
schnittlauch so startet einen gordon
ramsay
ist gerade ich glaube nicht allzu oft
wer ist eigentlich relativ fit und das
hat auf jeden fall in sie so zucker fett
aber sagt schmeckt sehr gut deshalb
[Musik]
war es ist fertig ist es ist knusprig
ist es süß ist so vollmundig geschmeckt
café das ist eine leichte frisch vom
schnittlauch also allein diese kreation
ist so krank weil du denkst so viele ab
in der scheibe brot pfeffer und die
chiliflocken gehen auch mit schärfe rein
was ich liebe und
sogar das hat sich durch alle ritzen
kommen wenn sie gezwungen das sind alles
nicht sooo allerwelts rezepte also die
haben auf ihre art und weise immer so
einen besonderen touch gehabt ist auf
jeden fall nichts was ich jedes
frühstück essen könnte aber es ist eine
willkommene abwechslung und auf jeden
fall sehr lecker so mein grill hat auch
schon bessere tage erlebt aber wir
werden ihn jetzt mal bemühen für das
mittagessen das was ihr seht ist alles
was man für den f word bürger braucht
für den berühmt gewordenen zudem das
zugehörige video 68 millionen auf
gefahren also ich glaube das ist
verteilt das meistgesehene sendung
überhaupt
[Musik]
wir fangen an mit dem ersten schritt
gegeben zuallererst ein wenig olivenöl
auf unsere bands die den geformt haben
ein bisschen salz dran das sind richtig
dicke wand sieht auch schon so 250 gramm
probe dann nehmen wir uns unsere bahn
sind hier auch bands gesagt ja natürlich
partys kommen sich sagt selbst er glaubt
fest daran dass man die bands von beiden
seiten an draußen musste die heute ganz
runter grund jetzt nehmen wir
so dass aus dem und jetzt ist der trick
das ganze so wenig wie möglich zu
bewegen und direkt den deckel drauf
machen dann haben wir hier unsere
zwiebel die wir in ganz sind grillen
herrn ein bisschen drauf dann bereiten
wir schon mal vor unsere tomaten noch
nie so eine perfekte tomate für bürger
gar weiter dies wirklich ein traum das
ist aber auch das was die golden reign
die bürger ausmacht wenn ich lass dir
immer so perfekt aussehen dass nach dann
haben wir so eine schöne form aber
zunächst auf der ober als auch die
unterseite eines
kinos mit die chance m2 sehr elektroden
quartier bestreichen jetzt die bereits
angriffe mit futter
jetzt wirklich einfach genau unsere
tomate zudem ist oben drauf sind dass es
zu perfekt ist schon schön jetzt im ziel
sieht auch schon richtig aus
kann sich sehen dass du streichen das
ganz schön mit butter kommt eine scheiße
und dann sind wir eigentlich schon fast
am ziel hat es auch zwei herzen ich
glaube was wir auf jeden fall nicht ganz
hinbekommen ist genau das gleiche
fleisch zu bekommen was vielleicht von
gordon hat mehr fett und ist deshalb ein
bisschen knuspriger so wird ja gesagt
ganz am anfang sagt ja auch dass er ein
break it genommen ja seine rinderbrust
ja es gibt sehr schwer zu bekommen
deswegen aber trotzdem dass es sehr gut
sein wird
[Musik]
achten wir 68 millionen views bürger von
gordon ramsay
verstehen wenn man ihn sich anschauen
und
das ernst und tue das feuer sei es auf
jeden fall guck dir das mal an
jeden fall sagt ich
schon stark auf fange ich es dann
möglich dass am besten essen weil er ist
so massiv sein da
er selber probiert auch im video nicht
welche laut ich
habe den kann man nämlich gut aussehende
es eine sache fehlt mir weil ich stimmte
nach rezept gemacht habe und falls das
fleisch nicht intern innen drin gesagt
dadurch dass das ein dickes partie ist
peter ein bisschen was ich meine großen
bissen davon erwischt ein bisschen
neutral aber von der saftigkeit und von
den einzelnen komponenten auch dieser
diese senf mario ist auch so krass diese
ganze tomate diese ganze ist wie der
fall das gefühl in sich gehabt so dann
kriegt jeder hin und dafür ist das
wirklich ein verrückter bürger also fest
dafür wirklich sehr sehr gut deshalb
wirklich einen burger mit der kein
schönheitspreis gewinnen also dass wir
drücke ich damals im mittagsschlaf und
dann sehen wir uns heute abend und wir
kommen zum haben es mit einer äußerst
lästig und es wird vor allem ein wort
gericht also wir brauchen nur diesen
einen topf und die haben von stinky so
große ziele knoblauch frühlingszwiebel
petersilie und reißt ihr werdet staunen
wie das alles zusammenkommt
zuallererst werde ich zwiebeln und
körperspannung
wird nur du musst jeden tag ein worden
wären sie rezept eben erst mal mit
ordentlich olivenöl ran an die sache und
da gebe ich zunächst einmal zwiebeln sie
während die show wenig farbe bekommt
befreit unsere story so man kann das
auch mit mehr geld oder bekannt oder mit
irgendwas machen also einfach so geboren
bist du noyer hat am besten die bereits
aus einem wursthüllen schneider kind
weil unsere würste ein wenig klein
gegeben unsere theorie sind nein rüsten
wir alles genannt
nicht wirklich schon so dass das brauch
ich richtig was auf die paprika
schneiden wir sind klein wirken
[Musik]
paprika rein gelassen das ganze mit
weißwein ab
jetzt eben ein bisschen reist an
einfach so über nacht stehen wir sehen
jetzt dass bereich sich dann alles
klarmachten gemacht wenn es aber es ist
man nicht alles was wir eingeben werden
bisschen damit ersetzen weil wir gehen
jetzt waren mit rinderbrühe es war so
dass alles schön verdeckt ist und
schwimmt und solange das ganze jetzt
etwa 20 minuten köcheln leinwand durch
damit stehen kann wer reich ist langsam
fertig man
gut das ist und hilft wenn es so ist
dann ist es ja erst
[Musik]
20 minuten sind vergangen und so sieht
das hier auch köstlich wenn ich ehrlich
bin da kommen so noch weitere frische
einzupacken und glatte petersilie vor
strikt den fleiß in tomatensorten papier
jetzt können wir noch mal durch kräftig
und dann kommt noch mal die frische man
muss es gerade lassen auch hier das
frühstück das geht nicht immer noch
nicht aus dem kopf waren so viele
geschmacks profile so viele
kombinationen so viele richtungen zur
süß salzig herz abbauen und hier erwarte
ich das gleiche machen teller und dann
probiert
was ich jetzt schon sehr an diesem
gericht schätze ist typisch für import
gericht dass nur eintopf das zu machen
was ich will also wenn das jetzt gut
schmeckt ähnlich gut wie die anderen
gerichte nun hat das auf jeden fall den
karten mein favorit heute zu sein
ich glaube ich habe sogar gehört hat ist
wie heftig das ist wie schlägt das ist
ultra so sick hat eine schöne schärfe
von der jury so hat eine frische und ist
mit der kochzeit mit dem aufwand zum
saubermachen auf jeden fall echt krass
ich finde wirklich das ist ein sehr
gelungenes hands down gordon ramsay
versus steffen henssler wir haben einen
tag rezept von steffen henzel gekocht
und rezepte von gordon ramsay gekocht es
ist eine frage des anders wenn man wenig
zeit hat geht steffen henssler wenn man
maximalen genuss will neben die rezepte
von auch die von stetten jetzt also in
kraft aber hier ist halt nicht alles
darauf ausgelegt möglichst schnell
gemacht zu werden sondern es hat alles
ein bisschen zeit und die zeit tut auch
den gerichten gut wie hätte es anders
sein können keine rezepte von gordon
ramsay bei alle drei hammer also danke
fürs zuschauen schreibt in die
kommentare bessere rezepte ich auch
testen soll und bis zum nächsten mal
machs gut j
[Musik]